the annual medicare fall open enrollment
period also known as the annual election
period is a time when people with
medicare can choose or alter their
medicare coverage but what does that
mean i spoke with dr richard orr from
southwest medical associates the
sponsors of this next segment to get
answers
thanks for joining us today dr orr
question so many people have what
exactly is medicare annual
enrollment it's a great question
your medicare annual enrollment is
actually your time and opportunity to
enroll in or make changes to your
current uh medicare or medicare
advantage health plan
it also actually allows you the
opportunity to select a primary care
provider it runs from october through
december 7th
it's also important to note that optimum
care network in nevada we have a large
array of physicians in both primary care
and specialty care and access to all the
major hospitals in the valley and
there's many benefits at southwest
medical including
uh
same-day access as well as annual
wellness visits
as well as virtual visits so a lot to
offer
and there is also something to offer
called medicare advantage now compared
to the original medicare can you explain
exactly what that is
that's a great question so whether
you're turning 65 or you're still
working uh so combined with the the
optimum care network in nevada and south
which includes southwest medical
um
the medicare advantage plan actually
offers many benefits designed to keep
you healthy
and like many other plans
the medicare advantage plans
offer numerous benefits including zero
dollar monthly payments
co-pays that are covered
some certain prescriptions particularly
generics that are covered with no copays
also includes limits to out of cost
out-of-pocket cost as well as some added
benefits in both visions insulin hearing
there's some other benefits including
fitness memberships wellness programs
among many other benefits that you won't
receive with the original medicare or
with even uh your general typical
employer insurance
and according to the uhd medicare
advantage cost savings uh report from
2020 the right medicare advantage plan
can save you 30 to 40 your overall
health care cost so it's almost like a
an upgrade or some added extras that you
can add on to your medicare plan
exactly numerous extra benefits too
numerous for us to sit and talk in one
sitting
but but a licensed sales agent can give
you
a great deal of information in that
regard
no yes you just mentioned a license
agent what is the best way for people
that are watching now to get more
information on this to follow up on this
and and have their questions answered
absolutely and so first it's important
to remember that open enrollment ends on
december 7th so whether you're enrolling
in a medicare uh advantage plan
or you're making changes to your current
plan or even selecting a primary care
provider it's important to note that
that's the last state that you can make
those changes so i do recommend you call
the number on the screen to connect with
an optimum care network nevada agent who
can connect you with a licensed sales
agent to discuss this in much more
detail and really help you out in terms
of making those really tough decisions
thank you to southwest medical
associates for sponsoring this segment
they have locations across southern
nevada call 702-608-0964
for enrollment information or visit
smalv.com